the united states is the capital
financial markets but it still doesn't
have a bitcoin spot etf there's a lot of
people wondering why is that so far the
sec has denied applications or continue
to push off decision making on the topic
there's plenty of different
organizations that continue to apply
they want a bitcoin spot etf we only
have a bitcoin futures etf and the
thought process is that spot etf would
be a much better product for the end
user now of course everyone at the sec
is in an agreement that actually we
should not have a bitcoin spot etf sec
commissioner hester purse came out
recently and said the regulatory agency
should stop denying spot bitcoin etfs if
we go look at her exact comments here
they are first she said it is time for
the commission to stop denying
categorically spot crypto exchange
traded products the commission's
resistance to a spot bitcoin etp is
becoming almost legendary that's a
legendary quote from her although
bitcoin is a new asset the concept of
affording access to commodities through
an exchange-traded product is not new
and finally purse followed it up saying
the continuing refusal of the sec to
approve a spot bitcoin etp is puzzling
to many agency observers the bitcoin
market has grown matured become more
liquid and attracted more and more
sophisticated participants now i tend to
agree with sec commissioner purse the
bitcoin spot etf is eventually going to
get approved it's not very clear why it
hasn't been approved already other
places around the world in many
developed nations those financial
jurisdictions already have bitcoin spot
etfs if the united states is going to
remain a leader in capital markets if
they're going to continue to say that we
are the capital of the financial system
then the bitcoin spot etf should be a
no-brainer at this point bitcoin has
hundreds of billions of dollars in
market cap there's plenty of market
surveillance and other things that will
address any sort of concerns that the
sec's has now of course we don't know
when the applications are going to get
approved but the next thing to pay
attention to is when grayscale's
application comes up in july they're
trying to convert gbtc from that bitcoin
trust into a bitcoin spot etf it allow
for redemption functionality and it will
likely close the massive discount in the
gbtc product today i have no clue if
it'll get approved or not but something
tells me that that's going to be the
next fight grayscale has said multiple
times publicly they're willing to do
whatever it takes to get it converted
from the trust structure into a bitcoin
spot etf it'll be fascinating to watch
but for sure they have an ally an sec
commissioner purse who believes it is
time for a bitcoin spot etf to be
released in the united states hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time